MANO MARKS: Hi, I'm
Mano Marks.
LUKE MAHE: And I'm Luke Mahe.
MANO MARKS: We're on the
Google Maps Developer
Relations Team.
We're here today to talk to you
about the latest version
of the Google Maps SDK
for iOS, version 1.4.
Let's take a look at some of
the cool new features.
LUKE MAHE: Well, the first big
feature we're launching today
is Street View.
MANO MARKS: Street View--
pretty awesome.
And we got it right
in the SDK.
And we've got support for adding
markers to it, as well.
LUKE MAHE: Yeah, and so this
is a really great feature.
If you're going to start
directing your user to a
location in your app, they
can actually load
up Street View now.
And you can start exploring,
which is really cool.
MANO MARKS: That
is really cool.
The next big feature is the
new look and feel that we
announced at Google I/O. So at
Google I/O, we announced that
maps.google.com would have this
new look and feel that
you can incorporate into your
JavaScript applications.
LUKE MAHE: So now if you
download the latest SDK,
version 1.4, you're just
going to get it.
MANO MARKS: That's right.
The next big feature
is Indoor Maps.
LUKE MAHE: That's very cool.
MANO MARKS: It is pretty cool.
So if your users zoom into your
map and we have floor
plans for buildings there,
we will show
them those floor plans.
And we'll even include
a floor picker.
LUKE MAHE: Yeah, the floor
picker's really cool.
You can change floors.
And if you don't want this at
all, you can just turn it off.
MANO MARKS: There's a lot
more that's actually
really cool in the SDK.
We've got [? zeroing ?]
for markers.
We've got an improved look and
feel for polylines, and a
bunch more.
So check it out at
developers.google.com/maps.
And check out the release notes
and the sample apps in
the SDK to explore some
of these new features.
LUKE MAHE: Well, that's all
we have for this week.
We'll see you next time.